we start this morning with breaking news
overnight in Colorado the husband of a
missing pregnant woman is in jail and
now charged with her murder
and the murder of their two young
daughters 34 year old Shannon Watts
four year old Bella and three year old
Celeste were last seen on Monday in
Frederick just north of Denver CBS
Denver station kaci NC reports that
christopher watts has admitted to
killing his wife and his young daughters
and he's agreed to take investigators to
their bodies later today
Jericka Duncan is following this
unfolding tragic story Jericho good
morning good morning Christopher Watts
has been charged with three counts of
first degree murder and three counts of
tampering with evidence he spoke with
local news stations after their
disappearance claiming he just simply
wanted his family home I have no
inclination of where she is
earlier this week Christopher Watts said
the last time he saw his pregnant wife
Shannon Watts and their two young
daughters was around 5:15 Monday morning
when he left for work it wasn't like her
not to answer a phone call or attacks
he said he became worried when he
couldn't reach his wife I came home and
it was like walking into a ghost town
CBS Denver station case TNC reported
late Wednesday that Christopher Watts
allegedly confessed to killing his wife
and daughters for you O Bella and
three-year-old Celeste he is now being
held at the weld County Jail I called
her and text her several times
Nicole Uthoff says she dropped Shannon
Watts off at her home around 2:00 a.m.
Monday morning following a work trip
later that day when she didn't return
calls Utah notified police after her
disappearance Christopher Watts
denied having an argument with his wife
emotional conversation but I'll leave it
at that the FBI and Colorado Bureau of
Investigation got involved Wednesday
authorities were seen searching the
family's suburban Frederick Colorado
home and towing away a truck late
Wednesday night do you guys have fun at
school
[Music]
on Facebook Shannon Watts portrayed a
happy family sharing photos of holidays
vacations to tropical places parties and
business trips she was 15 weeks pregnant
and posted on Facebook I'm excited about
August gender-reveal for baby watts
number three I just want them back I
just want them to come back before
allegedly making a confession
Christopher Watts pleaded for his family
safe return if somebody has her just
please bring her back I need to see
everybody I need to see everybody again
according to court records the couple
had financial issues in recent years
there is no known motive for the alleged
killings Shannan Watson's family said in
a statement they are deeply saddened
over the senseless and inhumane murder
of her and her daughter's viana we are
all saddened by that such a horrifying
story inhumane is the word it's it's
hard when you see the pictures of the
little girls dancing around and he's so
calmly saying please get my family back
it's one of those things that makes you
physically ill to your stomach hopefully
justice will be served